three constantly High Slackers a deadend
telemarketing job and a whole lot of
horrible people Workaholics was one of
the best shows about a group of dudes
doing a lot of nothing now that Blake
Adam and dur have said goodbye to Rancho
kukamonga it's time to take a look back
at everything that made Workaholics
possible
got come together a couple of the
Workaholics creators have been making
each other laugh since they were little
kids Kyle neich the guy who plays Dr
dealer Carl on the show and Blake
Anderson grew up together in Northern
California their first collaboration was
an elementary school era comic called
funion Protectors about anthropomorphic
funion snack Rings who were also
superheroes they started performing
together in high school and after
graduation moved to Orange County to
attend Community College which is where
they met Adam dine in an improv class
Anders Holm joined the group when he met
Divine at Second City in Los Angeles the
next upep making web videos Mail Order
Comedy back in 2006 six they launched
their Mail Order Comedy sketch Group
which was fairly successful even before
they landed on TV they had a bunch of
comedy shows did tours and were
basically going places among their
creative YouTube Ventures and their own
website they created two Myspace
exclusive comedy shows remember Myspace
if you do you're probably old hi my
name's Jasmine and I'm on MySpace I know
we've never met before but we should
meet because we live close to one
another is this a scam Once Upon a Time
time it was Facebook of its day so it
hosted a lot of exclusive media
including music comics and even web
series like the ones the Workaholics
guys did special delivery was a prank
show because every comic has to get the
prank stuff out of their system at one
point or another crossbows and mustaches
was an action comedy show that combined
two of the finest things ever created by
mankind of course Myspace couldn't last
forever so the Mail Order Comedy team
went on to make bigger and better things
experimenting with the ideas that would
eventually become Workaholics the Flop
House while taping the first season of
Workaholics Adam and Blake were
convinced that the show was going to be
a flop to save money for the Rainy Days
Ahead they actually lived in the
disgusting party house where the show
was taped while Anders lived in a real
home with his girlfriend Divine and
Anderson moved out when the show success
enabled them to afford proper shelter
but Anderson says the old place has
become a flop house where their friends
and family have crashed Anderson's
younger brother lived there for a while
as did divine's best friend from high
school nevertheless Divine says the
place remains infested with giant
newborn sized rats there was one like
24-hour period that we killed something
like 18 rats yeah we call it the night
of many Kill of many kills it's always
sunny and Rancho a show about a bunch of
terrible people doing horrible things of
course Workaholics is called and It's
Always Sunny in Philadelphia ripoff
which is basically a Seinfeld ripoff
anyhow Workaholics has been called that
since before it even aired and that was
by the creators even better they said
it's straight to the cast of Sunny
according to a movie web interview with
Blake before the show even aired the
cast of Workaholics drunkenly rushed up
to the cast of Sunny at a Comic-Con
party to tell them that their upcoming
show was basically a ripoff for what
it's worth the sunny crew reacted
positively and if there was ever any
doubt Sunny's Glenn Howton cast it aside
on Twitter straight out of Mordor the
season 1 episode muscle eyed like the
flex begins with a stylishly shot rap
video sequence in which the guys perform
a song about being Wizards while dressed
in Long robes beards and floppy hats
don't make this wizard mad don't make
this wizard piss I could kill a hill
giant with the flick of my wrist in the
plot of the show they're rehearsing for
a performance at a renaissance fair but
the wizard rap stick isn't new under the
name the wizards they recorded and
released a full album of wizard rap
called Purple magic in 2009 in fact they
wanted to pitch a show to Comedy Central
about Gangsta Wizards before a network
executive told them to go with their
other idea a show without Slackers
instead pong gone wrong in 2011 Blake
Anderson lived out out a real life event
that sounds like it could have happened
on an episode of Workaholics at a
wildhouse party in Los Angeles he raised
the stakes in a game of beer pong by
attempting to dunk a pingpong ball by
jumping off a roof the whole thing was
captured on video and ghoulishly sold to
[Applause]
TMZ the accident resulted in a pretty
serious spine fracture well he broke his
back for those of you that uh don't
snapped it
whoopsies he's got that like Dr Octagon
spine now I do Anderson underwent back
surgery but made a full recovery and
didn't miss a single episode of playing
a character who would have done the same
thing Arrested Development one of the
most surprising cameos on Workaholics
came courtesy of Mitch herwitz TV writer
and creator of Arrested Development
after the first season of Workaholics
aired he contacted the troop and told
them they were doing great work and that
he'd like to be a part of it in any way
they offered herwitz the opportunity to
write an episode but he wanted a chance
to ask so they wrote the part of cool
Eric the human resources guy for him I
love people to say that another way uh I
love people that one's got a little more
fun to it herwitz later repa the favor
by casting the three main stars of
Workaholics and Cameo rolls as Airline
employees in the 2013 Revival of
Arrested Development the end despite the
fact that Comedy Central probably would
have let the series Live Forever
Anderson Holm Divine and neich all
decided that the seventh season of
Workaholics would be the last in
statement the crew thanked Comedy
Central its Executives and the show's
fans quote for turning us from Boys to
Men it was an incredible run but we've
decided to leave on a high note get it
end quote while the show has ended the
team's collaborative efforts have not
they're working on an action comedy film
called game Overman for Netflix and the
conclusion of their show will leave them
more time to focus on bigger projects
written by Anders Holm the movie has
been described as an action comedy akin
to die hard in a hotel which honestly
sounds pretty fresh
[Music]
Archer burst onto the scene in 2009 hey
phrasing winning a loyal FX audience and
rave reviews from critics Adam Reed's
spy spoof mixed James Bond with The
Simpsons and the quickfire bite of
arresta development with the time
hopping 8ighth season going fullon film
Noir it's a perfect time to head into
the Danger Zone Danger Zone and reveal
some facts you may not have known about
Archer the ghost behind the Spy way back
in 1994 Cartoon Network took a chance on
an insane idea a cartoon talk show
hosted by a throwaway superhero from the
1960s that's what gave birth to Space
Ghost Coast to Coast that was the show
that eventually spawned the insanity of
the Adult Swim programming block which
has since become a cultural force on
television but it also led to the
insanity of Archer many years later this
is about conducting Espionage operations
for years with no Authority or
permission whatsoever from from the
United States government wait what
mother Archer showrunner Adam Reed got
his start working on Space Ghost as a
writer during seasons 4 through 6 Reed
then got to make his own show cab 2021 a
parody straight out of the space g
School of spoofing Hannah Barbara
cartoons the original 1972 show was cab
2020 an animated series set in the then
distant future where a scientist lived
under the sea and that's all anyone
remembers because the show lasted Less
Than 3 months Reed's parody had a longer
life and for good reason it was
hilarious and very Archer who needs
x-ray vision they'll beg to show their
to my
robot all that spoofing of 60s and 7s
cartoons sharpened Reed's comic voice
leading to Archer and thus a legend was
born let's be real Reed and executive
producer Matt Thompson use the real life
faces of friends acquaintances and
Industry pros from their home base of of
Atlanta to create the look of many
Archer characters as vulture reported in
2013 mallerie Archer is based on Atlanta
actress and Jessica Walter doppelganger
Kathleen Cohen Sterling Archer comes
from model Jason Fitzgerald's Atlanta
antique Steeler candy melanon is the
face of Pam and kinetta Lester a
Hooter's waitress Reed met after a
monster truck rally serves as the model
for Lana while Chris Parnell looks a lot
like the character he voices sirel he's
actually not the model instead the the
animators turn to Atlanta restur steuart
fearman for inspiration then there's
lucky Yates he voices creger but he's
actually the facial inspiration for Ray
who's in turn played by Show creator
Adam Reed confusing enough what are we
thinking what are we doing what are we
wearing my crisis vest Mr fat face as
for kerger his face belongs to Ben Brier
Reed's former College classmate which is
how creger got his name briger
volunteered his real name but Reed
altered it slightly to to give the man
some dignity well at least you got some
closure which is more than I ever got oh
you are just your mother all over luy's
early years speaking of Lucky Yates the
voice behind archers mad scientist ker
his first high-profile acting gig was on
the Food Network it's true Yates played
a wide variety of characters on Alton
Brown's wacky cooking show Good Eats
including a fishmonger a Butcher and the
infamous dungeon master
you've been a very bad dungeon master
and as punishment I want you to go skim
the
out lucky straw in a Reddit ask me
anything Yates had nothing but praise
for Brown saying the famous foodie is
even more hilarious in real life
crossing the line Archer is undeniably
edgy it's violent sexually explicit and
unafraid to poke fun at well just about
everything nice job Oliver Cromwell I
killed the pope but but believe it or
not some scenarios are forbidden even on
Archer according to showrunner Adam Reed
one script had Archer disarming a
terrorist by throwing his baby boy
Sheamus at him this didn't sit well with
the folks at FX who told Reed we're not
a network that throws babies a bold
stance it wasn't the only time FX put up
a fight in season 2 a young German girl
hits on Archer and in the original
script she was only 14 FX said that was
not okay eventually the two sides came
came to an agreement settling for 16
amazingly the age issue actually made it
onto the show I am from Germany they the
age of consent is 14 what is it the
Alabama of Europe in many ways yes
Archer imitating life in season 4
mallerie Archer married a car dealership
owner named Ron Cadillac much to the
Chagrin of Sterling Archer Cadillac is
voiced by Ron leedman who is not only
Rachel's awful dad on friends why would
you bring me SU
but is also actually married to Jessica
Walter who voices mallerie the thespian
couple has been hitched since 1983 and
were both known more for their dramatic
work until late into their careers I
don't know how to
wrestle well that's all right she showed
you right
boss mallerie Archer would never stand
for that Ker's codes when it comes to
Hidden jokes and messages Archer is
nearly unmatched take for example the
elaborate Easter egg leading fans to
Ker's Secret website it's complicated
but here's the gist in season 6 there's
a brief shot of serial numbers
associated with the character Conway
Stern if you plug that number into
something called a hex code translator
you get the address for a YouTube video
from there you have to fall far down the
rabbit hole to get to Ker's SES
including translating the sound in the
YouTube clip into an additional code
then using that code to make your way to
a fake Craigslist ad crack some more
code codes and on and on once you arrive
the username and password is hilariously
kriger and guest once you're logged in
you can play games view images and
download Ker's actual inow ringtone
toonic butts I tried Cal Pam Cheryl now
I'm even trying creger where the hell is
everybody
Tut it's a fitting thoroughly bonker's
tribute to a thoroughly bonker's
character spoke
bomb in 1989 Matt graining launched The
Simpsons 10 years later he created
another animated comedy classic futur
the series centered around a late 20th
century pizza delivery boy named Philip
J fry who gets stuck in a cryogenic
freezing pod on December 31st 1999 and
wakes up in the strange futuristic world
of new New York in the year 3000
Futurama had a devoted audience that
stuck with the show for over a decade
and now good news everyone here are some
amazing stories you might not have known
about futur armor a different name futur
armor was in retrospect the perfect
title for a show about The Amazing World
of Tomorrow still Creator Matt graining
had some other names that he liked
better on the first season DVD
director's commentary graining says that
his first ideas for the show's name were
Al Lowa Mars and doomsville but both
titles were met with indifference the
title they eventually settled on was
lifted from the 1939 to 1940 New York
World's Fair where visitors lined up for
the General Motors Pavilion and its
exhibit called future armor fairgoers
were welcome to the world of Tomorrow a
glimpse into the far off futuristic year
of 1960 welcome to the world of
tomorrow why do you always have to say
it that way haven't you ever heard of a
little thing called Showmanship fry and
Homer on Matt gring's first show The
Simpsons several of the main characters
were named after gring's immediate
family for example Homer and Marge
Simpson got got their names from gring's
parents futur Armor's lead character
Philip J fry was also named after
gring's father philli was his middle
name this means that Homer Philip
graining who died in 1996 had the unique
distinction of lending his name to two
major cartoon characters the voice of
Bender Bender bending Rodriguez the
sociopathic alcohol field bending robot
is probably futur Armor's most beloved
character bite my shiny metal ass it
doesn't look so shiny to me shinier than
yours meatbag voice actor John Demario
discussed his inspiration for Bender's
voice on the Kevin poock chat show it
was part it was part like drunk at the
end of the bar it was part um uh slim
pickings oh yeah you know what in the
hell in the wide Wide World of Sports is
it going on what in the wide Wide World
of Sports is it going on here throw that
in there and then you throw the there
was a guy my friend Ralph colino used to
do in col
and it was the Charlie the sausage lover
guy he loves sausages you have all kinds
of saus you have rot sausages you have
hot hot tight saus sweet Itali saus hot
Itali saus Germans they have worst all
kind of worst and he would just list
more and more sausages was ridiculous
and so it was like you throw all that
together in a blender and that's how you
get bender and interestingly dagio also
said he auditioned for the role of
Professor Farnsworth with the same voice
good news everyone of course he didn't
get the parts probably for the best Why
Not Zoidberg voice actor Billy West
pulled from two major old timey
Inspirations to create Dr Zoidberg actor
and host George Jessel I certainly want
to thank Phil for that warm introduction
I was listening to it for a minute and I
thought I was
dead and actor Lou jacobe why I just
caught the 745 elevator down from six
both of those Inspirations definitely
give a Jewish and Yiddish flavor to the
character which West says he thought was
appropriate giv given the traditionally
Jewish Berg suffix of the name Zoid
meanwhile is a futuristic alien sounding
word that has personal significance for
futur producer and writer David X Cohen
who while in high school created a
computer game named Zoid he submitted it
to brooder burn software which not only
rejected it but spelled cooh and wrong
in the rejection letter which seems like
something that could happen to Dr
zberg casting Phil Hartman the late
great Phil Harman specialized in playing
characters both obnoxious and oblivious
such as Bill mcneel on news radio he
also voiced a sleazy lawyer Lionel Herz
and watch up actor Troy McClure on Mt
gring's other show The Simpsons so it
makes perfect sense that Hartman have
been cast to provide the voice of
obnoxious Captain kires spaceship
captain zapa branagan on future armor
but after harman's tragic murder in 1998
Billy West stepped into the role he'd
once talked with Harman over their
shared love of oldtime radio announcers
that had big booming voices as well as a
huge sense of self-importance so West
performed zap branagan in that style as
a tribute to Hartman or at least how he
thought Hartman would have done the
voice why is it still blurry that's all
the resolution we have making it bigger
doesn't make it clearer it does on CSI
Miami it's the Beasty Boys futur Armor's
producers really wanted to line up one
of the most popular rap groups of the
20th century the Beasty Boys to play
themselves in the 31st Century too bad
at never actually happened according to
the DVD commentary for the episode hell
is other robots in which fry bender and
Leela go see the heads of the Beasty
Boys in concert writer producers Ken
Keeler and David X Cohen went to New
York to meet with the Beasty Boys but
never managed to connect eventually the
band members were recorded doing their
vocals separately well Adam ad Rock
horovitz and Michael Mike D Diamond
recorded their tracks Adam MCA York had
a scheduling conflict so ad Rock just
did his lines for him even after all
that the group wasn't entirely happy
with the material that Futurama writers
had prepared in the finished episode The
Beasty Boys perform a portion of their
1994 hit sabotage a capella oh my it's a
mirage telling you all it's
a they had initially been asked to do
their 1987 hit you got to fight for your
right to party and this style but
refused nevertheless there were
apparently no hard feelings because the
group gave a bit of a shout out to the
Futurama on their 2009 single too many
rappers one of the song's lyrics says
that they'll still be in the rap game
until the year 3000 and Beyond the sad
truth of Seymour Futurama was always
meant to be a comedy but some episodes
would occasionally touch on Fry's
sadness and the loss of being stuck in
the future having left his life and the
loved ones behind the 2002 episode
Jurassic Bark is one of those episodes
while visiting a museum fry discovers
the fossilized remains of his 20th
century dog Seymour Professor fransworth
tells fry that he could feasibly take
some of Seymour's DNA and create a clone
during the cloning process fry learns
that Seymour lived to be 15 he figures
that after he disappeared in 1999
Seymour must have lived a long happy
life without him and then the saddest
flashback ever broadcast on television
appeared Seymour didn't move on he
waited for fry outside the pizzeria
where he used to work for more than a
decade the episode ends with Seymour
closing his eyes passing away and
everyone watching in tears amazingly
this episode could have been even sadder
as revealed in the episode's DVD
commentary the writers toyed around with
fry finding the remains of his mother
and then considering But ultimately
dismissing cloning her that didn't stop
them from taking a tear-jerking dive
into fr's mommy issues in another
episode of
course oh
man
you're I can't stand to see him like
this
I'll push him off the
roof from Biblical symbolism to public
meltdowns to misleading negotiations a
lot has gone into the history of Two and
a Half Men and you'll never believe one
risque Favor John CER actually asked of
his co-star it isn't unusual for Pilots
to feature different actors from the
final cast announced for a series quite
often these Standalone episodes act as a
proof of concept and no one can predict
if a network will pick the series up in
fact many Pilots go completely unaired
in the case of 2 and A2 men the original
pilot most chicks won't eat ve featured
ble Danner in the role of Evelyn Harper
the matriarch of the family despite the
Pilot's success the Emmy award-winning
actress didn't stick around when the
sitcom was picked up by CBS according to
showrunner Chuck Lori the role just
wasn't perfect for the actress so she
was replaced by Holland Taylor you stay
out of this I'm here to help your
brother through a very difficult
time how could you do this to me however
some rumors suggest that Danner was
actually dismissed after she insisted on
making changes to some scenes that
didn't sit well with the producers of
the show replacing a star like Charlie
Sheen isn't easy yet the show was
determined to Soldier on without him and
sign up another actor to Star alongside
John CER in 2 and a Half Men before
Ashton Kutcher hopped on board there
were several other actors being
considered for the sitcom one of the
biggest names mentioned was Hugh Grant
who was reportedly offered a sizable
paycheck for the role according to
deadline in an interview with Howard
Stern Grant revealed that he was
contacted about a part on the show but
turned it down he explained that at the
time he was offered the part the
showrunners had not written a script
with the new character and asked Grant
to take a leap of faith to accommodate
their production schedule despite being
a fan of the show Grant's caution
prevailed and he declined the part they
make brilliant TV shows really but I
said I'm I'm too scared to sign up
without a script he joked to stern that
he does regret not getting the paycheck
when he realized how much TV stars
earned in the US Charlie Sheen's
departure from 2 and 1 half men was
quite the event making headlines around
the world and inspiring a generation of
quality memes and hashtags in the Years
afterward though many fans held on to a
glimmer of hope that he'd patch up his
differences with Chuck Lori and have one
last Rodeo on the show as it turns out
he nearly did for the series finale The
Producers reached out to him about a
potential appearance the plan was always
to drop a piano on Charlie Harper's head
however Sheen wasn't interested in this
particular ending pitching his own
suggestion a scene that sets up a
spin-off sitcom called the Harpers which
would have starred him and John CER
after the debacle that happened between
Sheen and everyone else involved on 2
and a Half Men let's just say that no
one jumped at his idea so the episode
went ahead with Lor's original ending
and without a cameo from Sheen while Two
and a Half Men focused on the
shenanigans caused by Charlie and Alan
Harper the heart of the show was Jake
who was played by Angus T Jones from his
Pitch Perfect comedic timing to his
Undisputed chemistry with his
illustrious co-stars the 9-year-old
Jones took all the acclamation right
from the get-go you get no
allowance that's your punishment for
gambling told you do that yeah you
did fans might expect that the casting
for the part of Jake was a long arduous
process but it wasn't in fact Chuck
lorri told Foundation interviews that
Jones was the first and only child actor
to audition for the role the showrunner
added that he had seen Jones's
performance performance as Hunter Morris
in 2002's the rookie and invited him to
read for the role of Jake after seeing
how much fun Jones was having in the
audition process and how nonchalant he
was about the whole thing the decision
to cast him was an easy one it's no
secret that the line where Charlie Sheen
ended and Charlie Harper began was a
blurred one at times many fans didn't
know if Sheen was simply playing a
character or himself however there was a
particular moment off screen when the
actor acted exactly like his TV
personality by lending a hand to John
CER in his time of need in his
autobiography so that happened CER
admitted that he was in a difficult
place after his divorce he decided to
hire a sex worker and Sheen provided his
co-star with expert advice on the
industry prior went on to explain
Charlie suggested a few online purveyors
he occasionally used as this was when
prostitution was gaining a foothold on
the internet he and I had different
tastes so I didn't go with his exact
recommendations in another case of Life
imitating art CER revealed that he w
brought a girlfriend to the set only to
be told by Sheen that he'd dated her in
the past and that they'd broken up
because she wouldn't allow him to bring
another partner into the relationship
when Ashton Kutcher joined Two and a
Half Men it surprised many people
including the actor himself Kutcher was
a big movie star who was proving himself
a bankable name in the industry so
returning to the sitcom world where he
got his start seemed like a backward
move in an interview with Howard Stern
Kutcher disclosed exactly what swayed
his decision to take the role of Walden
Schmidt his previous agent worked for
William Morris Endeavor a company that
was heavily involved with 2 and a Half
Men at the time Kutcher was considering
signing on the show was on track for
syndication if it was renewed for two
more seasons everyone involved could
expect a very nice payday Kutcher
revealed that when he found out Charlie
Sheen was making $1.8 million an episode
he told his agent he'd take the job if
he could get a similar deal reportedly
Kutcher didn't get the same offer as
Sheen but the rate he was offered was
clearly lucrative enough to attach him
to the sit for a full Four Seasons I
made a billion dollars doing this
billionaire entrepreneur Walden Schmidt
made his debut in Season 9 of 2 and a
Half Men where he buys Charlie Harper's
beach house and becomes Allen's new best
friend and eventual husband according to
Ashton Kutcher though the character of
Walden evolved quite a bit in an
interview on WTF with Mark Marin Kutcher
explained that when he met with Chuck
Lorie to discuss the part of Walden Lori
pitched a character very different from
the Walden that wound up making it on
screen the ACT never revealed the
changes made to the character between
the pitch and the first script but he
did bring up this observation to Lori
the showrunner told him Walden's
character Arc was going to take some
time to unfold so Kutcher put Faith in
Lor's vision and went along for the ride
seeing how hit sitcoms such as Will and
Grace and Matt about you have received
revivals in recent years many fans are
wondering if there's a chance that 2 and
a Half Men could get the same treatment
especially with the original Trio
reprising their iconic roles while
Charlie Sheen has pushed for it with the
Harper concept crier isn't exactly
rushing back to the Malibu beach house
anytime soon when asked about his
current relationship with sheen on
access crier stated it's kind of a
roller coaster when you have Charlie in
your life and I just haven't decided to
get back on that roller coaster maybe he
needs a few extra zeros on a new
contract to help twist his arm there
were several supporting characters on 2
and a Half Men but none of them had the
Charisma or hilarity of Berta the
housekeeper whether she was pointing out
the obvious or sticking around to laugh
at the Harper fallouts the outspoken
Berta never never missed a beat however
the character could have been very
different if it wasn't for the late Kata
fal's desire to do things her own way in
an interview with the AV club frell
explained that the showrunners had asked
her to adopt an Eastern European accent
when playing the character when she went
in for the audition she told the room
that despite the fact that she can do a
pretty solid Russian accent she thought
that adopting a quote trailer park
dialect was a better fit for the
character next thing I know I'm Belly Up
On the Floor hacking out along while the
cops are dragging out Bonnie and Claude
in handcuffs frell's performance
impressed Chuck Lori and everyone else
who decided to go along with her
suggestion in fact they loved it so much
that they extended her presence on the
show far beyond the initially planned
two episode Arc while the spotlight was
firmly on Charlie Sheen during his
ongoing feud with Chuck Lori hardly
anyone ever considered what the
showrunner went through as their
conflict unfolded Entertainment Weekly
reports that Lori was deeply hurt by the
ordeal so much so that he contemplated
leaving 2 and a Half Men in 2011 Lori
recounted a conversation he had with
other showrunners to TV Guide I offered
to quit the show last winter I said
listen if for some reason I'm now the
Antichrist I'm happy to leave it's not
in my interest to stop the show and I
certainly don't want to put all these
people out of work keep going get
another guy don't stop on my accounting
however CBS had Lor's back and he
described the Network's decision to fire
Sheen as a choice based on ethics rather
than money personal and professional
disagreements are common in any industry
including television
sometimes one party just might not be
feeling a script or the direction in
which the series is going they can even
part ways because of creative
differences but still remain friends
unfortunately Charlie Sheen didn't get
that memo not only did he burn his
Bridges with Chuck lorri but he also
painted the town red with metaphorical
Tiger Blood while it appeared that Sheen
would never squash his Feud with Lori
time does heal all wounds in an
interview with the guardian Sheen was
asked about his regrets the first thing
he said was that he should have handled
leaving 2 and a half men more
thoughtfully he also admitted to people
that there were numerous approaches he
could have taken to handle the conflict
and that he's unhappy with the one he
chose is it possible that by Sheen
admitting his wrong he and Lori could
work together again in the future
anything is possible in Hollywood
Charlie Sheen's departure from 2 and a
Half Men could have played out like a
scene from the show bad vibes and verbal
Jabs were thrown around in the Press
like a game of hot potato one of the
people who caught some collateral damage
in the process was Ashton Kutcher for
all intents and purposes he' done
nothing wrong by accepting the role of
Walden Schmidt in the sitcom however
that didn't stop Sheen from taking to
Twitter and insulting Kutcher on several
occasions Kutcher didn't take the
attacks lying down though and fired back
when required after a while Sheen's
comments stopped bothering him
completely Charlie Sheen has become like
a parent on Charlie Brown to me it's
more
like years later Sheen apologized and
admitted that he shouldn't have behaved
the way he did towards Kutcher Sheen
told the Kyle and Jackie O radio show I
was stupidly mean to him because I
overlooked the reality and difficulty of
taking over a show he also expressed
empathy for Kutcher explaining that he
had done the same thing by taking over
for Michael J fox on Spin City luckily
Sheen and Kutcher appear to have put
their beef behind them when Kutcher ran
into Sheen at a baseball game the pair
even shook hands out of all the
characters and 2 and a Half Men the most
memeable was alen Harper from him
constantly forgetting his wallet to
refusing to move out of his brother's
Malibu Beach House Allan was the
ultimate sponge however Chuck Lor's
initial vision for the character of
Allen was very different from the one
that appeared on screen in fact he and
the show's co-creator Lee Aronson PL
something of biblical proportions in a
conversation with The Hollywood Reporter
Lori said Allen was always designed from
the get-go to be kind of the biblical
job the good man who is trying his best
and can't catch a break and the
character has morphed over the years and
become much broader the showrunner
admitted that while that was the plan
the character Devi ated from it as the
series found its feet Charlie on the
other hand was supposed to be symbolic
of dianis the god of wine and fertility
that one seems to have stuck throughout
Charlie Harper had many lovers on Two
and a Half Men but there were a select
few who almost tamed the wild man one of
these individuals was Jennifer Taylor's
character Chelsea the actress had
appeared on the show in smaller parts
before being cast as Chelsea in season 6
what many fans don't realize is how the
sitcom gave Taylor the exact
professional and financial boost she
needed at the time while chatting with
entertainment journalist Jeremy Roberts
Taylor opened up about how she had just
given birth to her daughter and Was
preparing to sell her house to make ends
meet when she got the part she
considered the timing a good omen and
began filming for the recurring role in
2008 it doesn't get much better than
reruns of the office and sometimes you
notice things you never caught before
from creepy clown paintings to Call of
Duty screen names here are some of the
best Easter eggs to look out for the
next time you settle in to watch
America's favorite workplace in action
you even the most casual viewers of the
office know that the American series
didn't begin with an original idea it's
a remake inspired by a British show by
the same name this original series run
from 2001 to 2003 and focused on the
fictional Paper Company wernham hog in
the British town of slow the American
show takes place in Scranton
Pennsylvania but it still has a
connection to its British cousin's
Hometown in the season 5 episode blood
drive Michael pulls together a
depressing little Valentine's Day
shindig for all of his single co-workers
harboring secret hopes that he will be
able to reconnect with a woman he met
earlier in the day as he shows off the
flyer he's created for the event the
camera Zooms in revealing that the
address for Dunder Mifflin is 1725 slau
Avenue the address seems to be a nod to
the location of the original wornham hog
Paper Company it's not a onetime
incident either in the last episode of
season 6 Dwight refers to the street by
name again cancel it I want you to make
an offer at 1725 slow
Avenue make them an offer they can't
refuse the story of Angela and Dwight's
Secret Love is a long one starting early
on in the show and winding through
several ups and downs before they
finally tie the nut shw style while
standing in their own graves in the
series finale truly they're the show's
perfect match to the point where they
even seem to have the same favorite song
it's made clear from early on that
Angela is a huge fan of the Little
Drummer Boy every time a karaoke machine
is fired up that's the song she looks
for she even asked Sandy if they can use
it for their first dance when they're
planning their
wedding is there any way our first dance
can beat to my favorite song The Little
Drummer Boy with that in mind it's
interesting that and the pilot for the
show it's none other than the assistant
to the regional manager himself who is
shown aggressivly homing that particular
Carol as he sets up for
work no gifts for
you does this imply that the
relationship between the two goes back
even further than the beginning of the
show either way the connection seems too
clear to be an accident the whole teapot
episode in season 2 is an iconic moment
in the p and jym timeline after Michael
turns a simple secret Santa Christmas
party into an impromptu white elephant
gift swap Jim is frustrated to find that
his romantically intentioned teapot gift
for Pam has fallen into the hands of his
Nemesis Dwight get sinus infections and
sinus infections can be cured by making
your tea from Green Tea Leaf stems and
pouring it directly into your nose like
so Merry Christmas P ultimately makes
the right move though by choosing to
exchange a fancy new iPod for Jim's
thoughtful if humble gift instead but
that isn't the only time that the gift
appears in the show Almost 2 years later
in the season 4 episode Branch Wars Pam
meets with the extic refined Finer
Things Club that's the club enjoys a
fancy lunch the very same teapot Pam got
from a soon to be bow shows up on the
table he was hoping it had been washed
thoroughly hopefully several times since
Dwight shoved it up his nose while the
show focuses pretty tightly on a small
handful of characters the rest of Dunder
mifflin's employees usually have their
own lives going on in the background
complete with their own long running
plots take for instance Stanley's
troubled marriage which only gets worse
as a series goes on the issue even comes
to a head in the season 6 opener gossip
in which Michael leaks a secret of
Stanley having an affair to the entire
office while that episode ends with
Stanley getting a small measure of
cathartic Revenge it turns out that the
struggling salesman actually does want
to improve his relationships sort of in
the season 7 episode ultimatum Pam
encourages a co-workers to come up with
New Year's resolutions some of these are
minor items like Pam attempting to drink
less caffeine but others get pretty
ridiculous like Creed trying to do the
perfect cartwheel or Dwight search for
well let's just call it
romance my resolution is meet a loose
woman oh the resolution that has to take
the cake though is Stanley's double
commitment to quote be a better husband
and boyfriend each of those on their own
is an admirable goal but it might be
pretty difficult to pull off both at the
same time as the last two seasons of The
Office unfold Dwight slowly but surely
sees his life fall into place in
virtually every way he finds love
unwittingly has a son gets his black
belt inherits a 1,600 ACB farm and
finally at long last becomes the
regional manager of the Scranton branch
of Dunder Mifflin it's not just the big
stuff though Dwight's life is so perfect
that at this point that even his
smallest most obscure wishes start to
come true case in point the rocking
chair when Dwight accompanies Michael to
a cocktail party at David Wallace's
house way back in season 3 he spends
time admiring a wooden rocking chair in
Wallace's son's bedroom and declares
that he wants one for
himself oh good you're up Hey who makes
this chair cut to season 9 more than
half a decade later in the episode The
Farm twice is interviewed as he sits in
a gorgeous wooden rocking chair which
just so happens to look exactly like the
one he was wishing for six seasons
earlier Michael Scotts is proud of his
possessions and nowhere is this made
more clear than in the season 4 episode
dinner party in which Michael exhibits
his pathetically small plasma screen
television I will just stand here and
watch television for hours I love it I
love this TV later in the episode Jan
throws one of Michael's many dundy
awards at it cracking the screen and
infuriating Michael in the process that
isn't the last time we see Michael's
beloved and broken miniature TV though
the wall mounted Wonder made a cameo a
year later tucked behind another TV in
the fifth season episode Dream Team if
that wasn't enough it shows up yet again
nearly two whole Seasons later in the
episode garage sale sitting plain as day
on Michael and Holly's table it looks
like the more grounded influence of
Holly may have finally convinced Michael
to let go of his prized entertainment
possession once and for all as an
interesting little side note the garage
sale also shows the creepy clown
painting first seen when Jim buys Pama
house in season 5 hopefully whoever
bought it was able to keep it out of the
hands of the notorious Scranton art
thieves I tried to move it but he is
really nailed in there worried about art
theft I guess lot of art thieves in this
neighborhood in the season 2 episode the
injury Michael Scott wakes up and steps
on his George Foreman Grill Cooking his
foot in the process while the injury is
minor he ends up milking it all day long
when asked why he had a George Foreman
grill by his bedside in the first place
he explains that every night before he
goes to sleep he lays out six pieces of
bacon on a grill in his bedroom when he
wakes up he pops on the grill goes back
to sleep and then wakes up a second time
to the delicious smell of sizzling bacon
it is delicious it's good for me it's
perfect way to start the day it appears
that Michael's morning bacon habits die
hard the grill shows up yet again two
seasons later in the season 4 episode
dinner party as Michael and Jan give Jim
and Pam a rather uncomfortable tour of
their bedroom for all of her quirky
erratic Behavior Jan's apparently okay
with the smell of bacon each morning
after it's been sitting out all night a
good portion of season 3 follows Jim as
he tries to get away from his crush on
Pam and attempts to begin a new life at
the Dunder Mifflin branch in Stamford
one episode the coupe follows a Stanford
Squad as they practice team building
exercises by playing Call of Duty
against each other the group is highly
skilled at playing the video game at
this point but the Scranton newcomer
spectacularly fails to get on the
bandwagon
sabur sabur I'm going to kill you for
real in order to give a new coworker a
hand Karen shows Jim how to navigate out
of a corner only to shoot him a moment
later that's when we get to see her
screen name for these into office death
matches Karen the gym Slayer pretty
specific but also pretty appropriate
Michael scottt has been known to bend
the truth from time to time and that's
to be expected from a guy who was done
to mifflin's top salesman for 2 years
running back in the day when it comes to
his management skills though the man
seems a bit more insecure and determined
to prove a point there's the famous
world's best boss mug that he bought
himself one of the first things we see
in the show's pilot but that's not
Michael's only dubious claim to fame a
plaque holding a certification can
frequently be seen on the wall of his
office sharp eyed viewers May note that
it's not a diploma it's a certificate of
Authority for his watch even better
judging by the slightly misspelled brand
name it identifies Michael as the proud
owner of a knockoff while the writing on
the certificate can be difficult to make
out there's one episode where it's
clearly visible and it makes for an
often overlooked second layer to a gag
you can see it in the season 4 finale
goodby Toby which also happens to be the
same episode in which Michael is forced
to give his watch to Toby as a goodbye
president after being an awful boss for
so many
years I am going to give Toby your
watch
if that's not Poetic Justice we don't
know what is there's a good portion of
the series devoted to the ongoing duel
between assistant regional managers in
one corner of the Ring we have the
obvious candidate Dwight shro that's why
you have an assistant regional manager
yes it is assistant to the regional
manager same thing no it's not it's
lower so it's close his endless pursuit
to escape being the assistant of the
regional manager doesn't quite send
until he Leap Frogs the entire issue by
being made the full-blown manager in
season 9 at which time he appoints
himself was his own assistant to the
assistant to the regional manager in the
other Corner we have Jim Halpert while
he does spend some time as co-manager in
season 6 Jim actually climbs a corporate
ladder to the assistant regional manager
position much faster than that in the
season 3 episode the Wally Jim Karen and
Andy after work late and end up drinking
a bit too much while they're at it at
one point the camera shows Jim passed
out on his desk with his name place card
in front of him it reads Jim Halpert
assistant regional manager not a single
to the in sight seems we have a winner
most of the time Creed is the one in the
office who isn't quite what he seems I
run a small fake ID company for my car
with a laminated machine that I swipe
from the sheriff station however in one
episode it's none other than Jim Halper
who seems to have a secret identity as
all truly devoted fans will recall
season 4 kicks off with Meredith Palmer
being struck by Michael Scott's car it's
a banner incident in the show that kicks
off a running joke and even makes it
into the Montage of incidents referenced
in the Seasons of Love parody that the
crew sings to Michael at his very last
dundy ceremony right before he exits the
show in season 7 when Meredith returns
to work after the accident in the season
4 episode launch party she asks Jim to
sign her cast he agrees before realizing
that Meredith's injured pelvis has
presented him with a pretty unusual
place to sign a cast needless to say is
a little uncomfortable even without
Meredith's awkward flirting so
uncomfortable in fact that it might just
have broken Jim's character as he
awkwardly signs his name fans might
notice that it looks an awful lot like
it says John krinski rather than Jim
Halpert he even dots two eyes when he's
finished his character's name only has
one the Shan family is well known for
its sense of tradition longevity and
attention to detail well this can be
seen in everything from the venerable sh
Farms family home to Dwight's impeccable
work performance there's one thing that
sums it all up perfectly the American
flag not just any American flag though
we're talking about the one flying from
the porch of Sho Farms when some of the
group visits Dwight on his family farm
in the episode doomsday in season 8 they
pass a flag on the way out if you look
closely it's missing some Stars 35 to be
precise the 15 star flag was used
between 1795 and 1818 which also happens
to be the period during which Fruit
Farms was founded the accuracy isn't
just fun to spot it's also appropriately
located on the home of the most likely
person in the entire office who would
care about the detail like that in the
first place the season 5 episode The
Surplus follows the office as they
struggle to decide how to spend the
budgetary Surplus before it reverts back
to corporate the decision splits the
group into two factions one in favor of
getting new chairs the other for getting
a new copier critically Pam and Jim find
themselves on opposite sides of the
discussion making this one of the few
times that the newly engaged couple are
pitted against one another at one point
Oscar and Jim take Michael out to lunch
in order to smmo him about the benefits
of getting a new copier when they return
Jim brings Pam some tiramisu from the
restaurant Pam jokingly takes the gift
with a smile only to then throw it into
the garbage can in defiance clearly Pam
will not be bought off with fancy cake
the back and forth is comical but it
turns out that the delicious dessert
hasn't hit the end of the line quite yet
a bit later in the episode Michael is
scene eating terisu as he talks to David
Wallace on the phone then to bring or
home during a big speech designed to
cover the fact that he's shooting for a
bonus by returning the Surplus to
corporate Michael reveals where he got
his snack from as he berates the office
for being spoiled we are spoiled because
we throw out perfectly good tiramisu
because it has a little tiny hair on it
the most surprising thing that's not
even the weirdest food Choice Michael
makes in this one episode every show has
its list of slip-ups and continuity
mistakes the office for instance will
occasionally show an exterior shot with
a suspiciously Californian palm tree and
what supposed to be a chilly morning in
scr Pennsylvania something that's
especially noticeable in season 3's
traveling salesman there are a few
others that slip through the cracks
though and you can spot one in season
8's pool party in the episode the staff
heads over to Robert California's house
after hours in order to throw one last
party before he sells the home off to
the highest bidder While most of the
crew spends time taking advantage of
their buses luxurious indor pool another
group is taken on a long boozy tour of
the Mansion led by Mr California himself
as they go along observing each room and
sucking up to California as he endlessly
monologues each member of the tourist
gifted with their own bottle of wine
recklessly taken from the soon to be
sold wine seller at one point as they
observe a king-sized bear rug made from
two bears sewn together Oscar takes a
swig from his bottle only to reveal a
note on the bottom that reads Oscar that
wasn't there earlier either the
accountant is extremely particular about
labeling his things or somebody forgot
to remove the prop label before the
camera started rolling the officer is
known for having some of the best cold
opens in sitcom History Michael and
Dwight's attempt at making a parkour
video Michael's truly incredible worldly
gift Worthy reaction to Toby's return
Randle Park's appearance as Asian Jim
for one of the most elaborate entries in
Jim and Dwight's ongoing Prank War
they're all classics but one of the best
cold opens for the show takes place in a
season 3 episode product recall in it
Jim arrives for work decked out on an
outfit that makes him look just like
Dwight from the dorky haircut to the
glasses short sleeve shirt and beeper
the entire ensemble is on point Bears
beats Battle Star Galactica after his
initial arrival Jim explains that he got
the outfit on the cheap spending just
four bucks on the glasses and pulling
the rest of the pieces together for a
mere 77 extra dollar according to the
total that he adds up on his Dwight S
calculator watch the grand total for the
prank was a very affordable sum of $1
it's a memorable joke and one of the
highlights of the series but what really
puts it over the top is a subtle moment
that were treated to at the end of the
episode Angela frustrated by a day of
filling in on customer service calls
rips into Kevin for failing to add up
the numbers on a payroll form correctly
the numbers in question the same ones
added up on the calculator watch back in
the cold open 4 + 7 that's a little
little too specific to be a coincidence
so we're left with one amazing fact not
only did Jim pull off an A+ prank but he
also managed to get reimbursed for it as
a business expense hey if Michael can
spend company money hand over fist for
all those big dinners at the local
chilies then Jim should be able to
expense C and kurd while boosting office
moral the only question left is whether
Dwight thought to file those same forms
when he dressed up as
Jim it's been 20 years since Seinfeld
left TV and its ratings grabbing final
episode remains divisive among both
critics and fans
here's what happened during the last
episode of this long running sitcom and
how it fits into the rest of the hug
free learning free laugh-filled show
about nothing so everybody I know is a
character on the show right and it's
about nothing absolutely nothing
breaking the mold while sitcoms existed
before Seinfeld no other show captured
the quirks of everyday life quite like
it older sitcoms relied on likable
characters and Goofy hij Jinks but
Seinfeld in contrast famous had the
unofficial motto of no hugging no
learning in one of many tongue-and-cheek
plots we even watched characters pitch a
Seinfeld esque show to an NBC executive
as a show about nothing I think I can
sum up the show for you with one
word
nothing nothing nothing the show's
tendency to make episodes out of
anything meant that viewers had no idea
what the show would focus on week to
week viewers could jump in anywhere
without getting lost and the characters
of Seinfeld would never learn a lesson
even if they really should that all
changed in the series finale looking up
the series finale starts off on a
positive note Jerry and George seem to
have finalized their deal for the
Seinfeld es show they're making called
Jerry he wants to sit down with us and
talk about Jerry a show Jerry right
Jerry oh my God he wants to talk about
Jerry yeah Network executives even loan
the cast a private jet so Jerry and his
Pals decide to go to Paris it's about
the happiest ending the self-obsessed
crew could get so of course it doesn't
last almost immediately they muck things
up by nearly crashing the plane and get
stuck in a small Massachusetts town
while they wait for it to get fixed in
classic Seinfeld fashion they witness a
crime and crack jokes instead of helping
the
victim that's a shame all right I to
call NBC however the characters aren't
in New York and they're big city
attitude lands them in court for failing
to help they finally experience real
consequences for their daily rudess
almost as soon as they leave New York
karma for past Deeds of course it's
ridiculous that they're arrested for
failing to help a carjacking victim
especially when as their lawyer reminds
the judge the actual criminal is still
out there so how can a bystander be
guilty no such thing have you ever heard
of a guilty bystander still you can't
say that Jerry George Elaine and framer
didn't have it coming in some way so
they just stood there and did nothing
yeah nothing nothing the actual crime
they get arrested for might be criminal
indifference but the real reason that
they get arrested is that they've
amassed so much negative Karma over the
years that something needed to break
even their acts of kindness are tainted
with selfishness like when George tries
to take back a tip when the cashier
doesn't notice him originally tipping
character Witnesses during their trial a
series of character Witnesses become a
greatest hits parade of some of the
funniest Seinfeld episodes while also
reminding viewers just how many awful
things the cast has done but the idiot
clowns did not know how to order I
banned that one the woman for a year
then one day she came back instead of
taking the opportunity to realize how
many people they've hurt Jerry Elaine
George and Kramer seem largely unmoved
and then they're judged we find the
defendants
guilty and sentenced to a year in prison
nothing ever ends oh yeah the second
button is the key button it literally
makes or breaks the shirt look at it
it's too high it's a no man's lamp after
they get convicted Jerry talks to George
about his shirt button placement in an
exact rehash of the very first lines of
Seinfeld see now to me that button's in
the worst possible spot
the second button literally makes or
breaks the shirt look at it it's too
high it's a no man's land George
responds by asking if they've had the
conversation before and having
completely ignored any chance to redeem
themselves the show ends exactly where
it begins with George and Jerry having a
conversation about nothing controversial
conclusion love it or hate it the ending
is certainly bold unfortunately it was
also pretty divisive Entertainment
Weekly gave it a c minus at the time
while USA Today published a scathing
review of the finale on the other hand
Grantland published a defense of the
finale in 2015 it wasn't just critics
who were torn either the actors were
divided about the unique ending Jerry
Seinfeld himself initially defended the
show in a Reddit AMA saying I was happy
with the Seinfeld finale because we
didn't want to do another episode as
much as we wanted to have everybody come
back to the show we had so much fun with
Julia Louie dfus who played Elaine even
made a joke about the finale on The Late
Show with David Letterman thanks for
letting me take part in another hugely
disappointing series
finale not the real ending while the
actual finale of Seinfeld might still be
debated it's not necessarily the final
word from co-creator Larry David on Curb
Your Enthusiasm David put together a
Seinfeld finale more in keeping with
fans expectations when he brings the
cast back together and aoy to regain the
affections of his ex wife Larry we
already screwed up one finale we can't
do another we didn't screw up a finale
that was a good finale in the reunion
Jerry has gotten together with Elaine
while George tries to get back together
with his ex-wife Amanda after losing all
of his money in a pyramid scheme Jerry
and Elaine have even had a daughter
together the ending is much closer to
what fans likely pictured when Seinfeld
was wrapping up his run and David even
called the fox reunion quote a perfect
way to do something like that but not to
do
it few people in the entertainment
industry of the '90s had more power than
Tim Allen in addition to a thriving
career in stand-up comedy and roles in
movies like the Santa Claus Galaxy Quest
and Toy Story he started on ABC's Home
Improvement one of the most watched TV
shows of the decade based on a major
element of his comedy acts that men were
still essentially IL equipped cavemen
and had evolved only enough to enjoy
power tools Allan played Tim the Tool
Man Taylor Tim was a bumbling husband
and father and host of Tool Time a
Michigan based home improvement show
which invariably ended ended up with him
breaking something here's a look behind
the scenes of ABC's 8 season
smash A Tale of Two jails Patricia
Richardson wasn't the first actress to
play the role of Tim Taylor's
long-suffering wife jaill who's that
supposed to be is that supposed to be me
no that's not you actress Francis
Fischer originally landed the role and
performed it for the pilot taping while
the inaugural episode was successful
enough to get the show on ABC schedule
test audience didn't like Fisher in the
role so with little time to spare before
production started the show Runners
replace fer with Richardson even though
it wasn't ideal timing I had just given
birth to yeah two babies and I really
was supposed to do another show for ABC
and and that was supposed to happen nine
months later so I was going to have all
this time to lose the weight and and go
be with my babies the other show was
cancelled though so they offered a
double salary to play as jail Richardson
warned producers that there might be a
set delay as a result of a new
motherhood I said look I'm nursing twins
you have to wait for me for for 40
minutes while I'm doing that and and
they said oh well we'll yeah we'll do
anything and so the new mom started
raising her onscreen kids alongside her
real life babies you can almost call him
Al you probably know character actor
Steven to balowski from just about
everything from Groundhog Day to Silicon
Valley to The Goldbergs but the actor
could have had a long-lasting regular
gig on Home Improvement if he wanted it
to balowski originally won the role of
Al Balland Tim Taylor's longsuffering
extra competent tooltime assistant he
walked away however when they couldn't
assure him of a proper start date and
still wanted an exclusive contract
tobolowsky told splitsider I couldn't do
any other work any other shows which is
normal on a regular show that my wife
was pregnant we had a baby coming I had
auditioned for a couple of movies and
was waiting on them and they said I
couldn't do movies rather than risk
being broke for months toal lovi parted
waves with Home Improvement and the part
of being the butt of every joke went to
Richard Khan instead W look at that butt
crack you got going
there actually Jud needs no improvement
Pamela Anderson's high-profile career
really started when she played Lisa the
tool girl on to Time the show within a
show on Home Improvement but
awardwinning star and activist Ashley
Jud also tried out for the parts when
she auditioned for the Show creator Matt
Williams thought she was so talented
even too talented for the somewhat
thankless eye candy role of Lisa
Williams called jud's agent and said
that while she didn't get the part he
was going to create a role just for her
as Tim Taylor's sister but that offer
was declined and she went on to Star an
NBC's drama sister instead Chappelle's
first show Home Improvement might not
seem like the kind of vehicle to propel
the career of one of the most incendiary
comedians of all time but it did on a
1995 episode of Home Improvement Tim
Taylor's Tool Time descended as it often
did into a discussion about how marriage
can be tough Tim asked if anyone in the
studio audience had like him been
tricked into a fight with their
significant other two guys named Dave
and Jim could relate and Tim pulled them
up on stage well what were you thinking
I was thinking of calling you no you
weren't yes I was no you weren't as Dave
Chappelle lit up the screen impressing
ABC Executives so much that they
commissioned a show about the duo called
buddies it debuted in 1996 with some
changes including the replacement of Jim
breur with Christopher Garten only a few
episodes a before buddies was cancelled
but landing a Prime Time network TV show
couldn't have hurt Chappelle's early
exposure efforts Emy snafu most TV fans
probably don't know that performers have
to submit their own names for
consideration for the Emy Awards and
apparently NE did Tim Allen Home
Improvement was the actor's first major
small screen role and he didn't know how
the Emmys worked at first when Emmy
nominations were released in the summer
of 1992 after Home Improvements first
season Allan wasn't snubbed for
outstanding lead actor in a comedy
series he just hadn't submitted his
paperwork after somebody told him the
rules Allan made sure to get his name on
the ballot the next year he was
eventually nominated that year but lost
out to Ted Danson from cheers but Allan
just couldn't win his team forgot to
submit his name for consideration the
following year much to his
disappointment oh no oh no oh no
uhoh
[Music]
uh-oh not a word you want to hear in
this house to Time meets game time
sitcoms on easy to turn into video games
but Home Improvement was so popular
during its run that a game called power
tool pursuit to debuted in 1994 for the
Super Nintendo the plot of the game is
that a new line of power tools by Tool
Time sponsor Binford tools had been
stolen right before Tim Taylor is
supposed to unveil them on the air Tim
goes on a quest in search of the tools
using other power tools to defeat
enemies like dinosaurs mummies ghosts
and other creatures which definitely
weren't a part of the average home
improvement episode in keeping with the
show which often touted the dumb Macho
of cuff ways that real men should act
the game's manual consisted entirely of
the message real men don't need
instructions now there is RA power with
a JT Home Improvement played to a lot of
different demographics adult fans love
Tim Allen's destructive Antics or many
tween girls tuned in for Jonathan Taylor
Thomas of the three young actors playing
the Taylor kids jtt is the one who
became the major Teen Idol his face
appeared on the cover of all the major
magazines and poster foldouts and he was
the stuff young crushes were made of
despite the overnight Fame he earned
from the show though Thomas left the
show in 1998 he told People magazine
I've been going non-stop since I was 8
years old I wanted to go to school to
travel and have a bit of a break he
enrolled at Harvard studying philosophy
and history but he also acted in a
couple of movies that didn't sit well
with Alan he was confused as to why the
young Star had left Alan told TV Guide
he said it was about going to school but
then he did some films did he want to do
films did he want to go to school after
Alan confronted Thomas onet their Feud
became so bad that the young actor opted
not to return for the series finale
Thomas and Allan must have patched
things up at some point since then
however because Thomas guested on four
episodes of Alan sitcom Last Man
Standing and his appearances even
included some cheeky references to their
history you know a lot of times that
middle child ends up being the funny one
because he wants the attention man he
looked
familiar the season That Never Was Home
Improvement wrapped up after eight
successful seasons in 1999 and it was a
decision made by the casting crew rather
than ABC while he grew sentimental and
upset as the finale neared Alan also
regretted not ending the show a year
earlier when the show was still a top
five ratings hit in its final season
Home Improvement fell to 11th Place in
neelson rating things but ABC wanted to
go even longer the network even
reportedly offered Allan as much as $50
million and Patricia Richardson 25
million to return for one more season
somehow though Alan and Richardson
managed to leave that money on the table
and the world's time with the toour man
was
done the 1990s brought a tidal wave of
sitcoms crashing onto television's
Shores some were amazing some were
terrible but all of them in time came to
an end these are the strangest most
interesting and most surprising stories
of 90s sitcom cancellations from The
Fresh Prince of Bel Air to Frasier
Freaks and Geeks transcended its sitcom
status ultimately becoming one of the
defining teen shows of the 1990s
unfortunately much of its reputation is
postumus it was cancelled after one
season and never given another chance by
NBC high school is for learning but it's
also where you should be learning how to
socialize the show debuted at 8:00 p.m.
on a Saturday an awful time for a new
show especially one aimed at teens
Freaks and Geeks then changed time slot
hampering any chance at building ratings
The Producers created a website a rarity
at the time for TV shows to help fans
keep track of when it was on but NBC
refused to put the URL on any
commercials lest viewers gravitate
towards the web instead of TV there were
also tensions between the producers and
the network NBC wanted a more positive
show while the producers wanted to keep
things realistic executive producer Jud
appow became particularly known for
viciously defending his show to any and
all Network Executives in the end the
show was cancelled but its Legend has
only grown Phenom a sitcom about a
tennis Prodigy and her family lasted one
season and has largely been forgotten
the show had a lot going for it at the
start and perhaps more importantly it
had a great time slot right after the
mega hit Full House so why was it
canceled depends on whether you ask ABC
or the producers ABC implied it was
canceled because it underperformed
reviews indicated a lack of direction
for the show but this was still a shock
to fans Phenom Creator and Executive
Producer Dick Luchi was also surprised
the show was asked he claimed that even
though their own metrics showed good
ratings ABC told them that their numbers
didn't match Minnie saw this as code for
a network looking for an excuse to cut a
show Third Rock From the Sun followed a
group of aliens masquerading as an upper
middle class American Family studying
human habits and Reporting back it was
was if you'll excuse the space pun a far
out show that dabbled in everything from
witty word play to slapstick it had a
great cast including John litho and
Kristen Johnson and introduced the world
to Joseph Gordon levit the show was
off-kilter enough to have dedicated fans
but it had a hard time maintaining
casual viewership thanks to a frequently
changing time slot the network didn't
believe in Third Rock in spite of its
longevity as such the finale of season 6
was designed as a series finale and the
creative team signed on for different
projects correctly suspecting the show
was done the cast ultimately accused the
network of having mishandled the series
Will Smith's career trajectory from
rapper to living with his Auntie and
Uncle in Bel Air to the world's biggest
movie star is a strange Arc starting as
the fresh prins with DJ Jazzy Jeff in
the 1980s Smith got rich from his music
only to blow all his money on an
unsustainable lifestyle after getting in
trouble with the IRS he signed on to
star in a sitcom largely because he
needed the money luckily for him the
fresh prince of belir went on to become
one of the most memorable sitcoms of the
9s running the gamut on topics from
normal teen issues to somber dives into
racial discrimination it was such a hit
that it never left its 8:00 p.m. Monday
time slot during its entire run by the
end of the series Smith had become a
mega star in addition to the leading
role on Fresh Prince he also had six
degrees of separation and bad boys under
his belt and he was set to star in a
movie you may have heard of called
Independence Day Smith loved his cat
classmates but recognized the show was
limiting and knew it was time to move on
he had something bigger in mind
goodbye
will bye-bye
G The Fresh Prince was cancelled largely
because Smith was ready to move on to
the big screen full time few sitcoms
come longer running and better loved
than Frasier starring Kelsey gramar as
radio psychologist Frasier Crane the
show went through almost the entirety of
the 9s and Beyond originally a spin-off
of Cheers Frasier stuck around a season
longer than its predecessor but why
would such a long running and successful
sitcom get cancelled part of it was a
ratings dip yes but the larger part was
unsustainable production costs long
running shows often see higher
production costs given that actor
salaries tend to rise and more care is
put into the show Itself by the end of
the final season each episode of Frasier
cost over $5 million to make $1.6
million of which was grammar's salary he
implied he'd be interested in a 12th
season and might take a pay cut but an
NBC spokesperson said the network just
couldn't see the numbers working so the
show's writers decided to end things on
a high note thank you Fraser
for well you
know Strangers With Candy was one of the
most bizarre and acclaimed comedy shows
of the late '90s starring Amy Sedaris as
Jerry blank and featuring comedy icons
Steven bear and Paul danello the show
was a hit on Comedy Central it ran for
30 episodes over three seasons in 1999
and 2000 its weird Twisted morals alone
make for some of the best comedy of its
era even though it's mostly a cult hit
as such Strangers With Candy often makes
lists of shows that were cancelled too
soon here's the catch though according
to Sedaris the show was technically
never cancelled in that era most Comedy
Central shows only lasted three seasons
and The Strangers With Candy team
operated under the assumption that
they'd be no different sideras later
noted that the final episode of the
series was simply written assuming it
would be the last and it just worked out
that way Martin was one of the highest
rated sitcoms during Fox's rise in the
early '90s by the end of the show's run
it was still the third most watched show
among black viewers it was a hit however
you slice it and still does well in
syndication when it ended somewhat
abruptly After Five Seasons star Martin
Lawrence said it was because he felt it
was just time to move on this sounded
plausible enough at the time thanks to
Lawrence's budding movie stardom of
course even in the pre-twitter days
Lawrence was enough of a public presence
that most people suspected differently
his erratic Behavior was making
headlines even before co-star Tisha
Campbell filed a sexual harassment
lawsuit against him after she quit the
show the lawsuit was settled and
Campbell only appeared in the series
finale on the condition that she didn't
have to be on set with Lawrence Lawrence
told GQ magazine in January 2020 that he
regretted a lot of his behavior in the
'90s he also openly acknowledged for the
first time that he walked away from
Martin because of the lawsuit Martin and
Campbell are reportedly on good terms as
of late so there's at least a happy
ending as the latest addition to NBC's
everever expanding library of sitcoms
young Rock has already taken the
television World by storm in case you
haven't seen it the story of young Rock
goes like this Dwayne The Rock Johnson
is running for president but wants to
better connect with the people in hopes
of securing their vote to do so he joins
W division's own Randall Park to shed
some light on The Man Behind The Myth
telling crazy stories from his childhood
sharing life lessons that got him
through hard times and showing there's
more to him than meets the eye oh and
I've got some pretty cool stories about
Andre the Giant with one episode
released so far there's no denying the
former Scorpion King actor went through
quite an unorthodox upbringing The
Rock's developmental years proved rather
unconventional his father the late Soul
Man Rocky Johnson made ends meet by
working as a professional wrestler and
as a consequence kept his family on the
road most of the year as a byproduct of
that lifestyle the young Dwayne Johnson
AKA Dewey spent a lot of time around his
dad's co-workers including the likes of
the iron Chic junkyard dog and the
eighth wonder of the world himself Andre
the Giant you know when you grow up
around wrestlers sometimes you learn
lessons in very interesting ways casting
such a larger than life character for
young Rock surely wasn't easy but
Matthew willig ultimately landed the
role here's where else you might
recognize the massive actor from born
and raised in larada California Matthew
willig grew up playing sports
particularly basketball and football he
carried this interest into his college
Years where he played football at the
University of Southern California
playing a role on the winning team of
the 1989 Rose Bowl this success didn't
go unnoticed inevitably leading to
willig joining the National Football
League in 1993 as an offensive tackle
for the New York Jets he played with the
Jets until 1995 when he was scooped by
the Atlanta Falcons who kept him around
for two seasons afterwards he signed
with the Green Bay Packers in 1998
followed by the St Louis Rams in 1999 he
didn't actually see any playing time
that season but his team did get the
victory at Super Bowl 34 earning himself
a Super Bowl ring as the 2000s began
willig found himself on the roster of
the San Francisco 49ers he stayed with
the team until 2002 when he jumped to
the Carolina Panthers the team that sent
him back to the Super Bowl for the 38th
big game he wrapped up his NFL career
after the 2005 season once again as a
member of the St Louis Rams it's an epic
career in a position that boasts an
average lifespan of about 3 and 1/2
years in the pros but even after
retirement willig was just getting
started on the football field being a 6'
8 in mountain of a man certainly has its
benefits when it comes to the bright
lights of Hollywood however it also
provides a kind of Niche willig's big
screen tenure kicked off in 1993 in
action movie full contact playing the
aptly named character of Hulk years
later after his NFL career had run its
course willig popped up in the 2006
Sports comedy The Benchwarmers as an
unnamed jock establishing a trend of
taking minor roles that play to his
unique frame willik put this asset to
use for comedy sake in 2009 for the
prehistoric Jack Black and Michael Sarah
project year 1 portraying the Burly
marlac a proficient Hunter who's more
than capable of of manhandling Jack
Black's character his next most
high-profile gig arrived in 2013 once
again working in the comedic realm for
We're the Millers acting as a menacing
drug dealer alongside Jason sedus and
Jennifer Aniston in 2015 he tried his
hand at more dramatic Fair appearing as
deceased football star Justin strelzik
in the biographical Sports drama
concussion 3 years later he teamed up
with the Cohen Brothers for a small part
in The Ballad of Buster Scruggs striking
in intimidating posture in a role
credited as Cantina scum his most recent
cinematic Works include a role in heavy
metal icon Rob Zombies 2019 horror film
three from Hell Followed by a small part
in 2020s Birds of Prey of course these
examples are only a small portion of his
entire filmography which also includes
lesser known releases like short films
and direct to video movies even in those
smaller projects he obviously has a
tendency to stand out 2006 marked the
beginning of his television work that
year he made one-off appearances on
Malcolm in the Middle The West Wing and
Everybody Hates Chris the next year he
appeared in two episodes of Dexter and
he also made appearances on NCIS and The
Young and the Restless with the 2010s in
full swing willig's TV workflow held
strong bringing him Parts in shows such
as Grim Brooklyn 99 and Agents of Shield
on which he played the role of the
inhuman lash for six installments of the
show's third season aside from hisle on
young Rock his more recent credits
include two episodes of flaked and three
of blunt talk as well as a cameo on the
guest book in 2018 and Charmed in 2019
the guys clearly got the frame for genre
for now willig is expected to continue
appearing in the first season of young
Rock considering his lengthy resume and
his unique physicality it's hard to
imagine he'll be dropping off the radar
anytime
soon at its core American Dad is a
family sitcom crossed with the craziest
elements of spy movies and Science
Fiction more than 200 episodes of the
series have aired centered around CIA
agent Stan Smith his family their living
alien Roger and a talking fish named
clouse here's a look behind the scenes
of American Dad the evolution of klouse
American Dad is almost definitely the
only show on TV to have a goldfish who
speaks with a German accent that's
clouse a once human German ski jumper
whose brain was switched with a goldfish
by Cutting Edge CIA technology and who
now lives in a bowl at the Smith
residence hour
36 the sun seems like it comes every day
now the cat's back Not only was clous
once human he was also once French
series co-creator Seth McFarland
explained D Baker it was interesting the
the character of clous was originally
supposed to be French and remember that
D had come in to do uh some animal
sounds on
family and uh and had kind of warmed
himself up in the booth by doing this
German accent McFarland fell in love
with Baker's alter a take on the fish
and Baker got the part beating out Billy
West and John demaggio of Futurama they
dropped the politics a show about a very
conservative CIA agent who lives and
works in the Washington DC area is bound
to be at least a little political but
the American Dad writers have toned down
that kind of content over the years it's
not because the show's networks fox or
TBS told them to or that they were
afraid of offending viewers they found
that political references dated the show
for example in 2005 President George W
bush nominated White House Council
Harriet Myers for the Supreme Court
American Dad wrote in a joke about her
but Bush withdrew the nomination a few
months later the episode with the Myer's
joke aired co-creator Mike Barker told
the AV club I remember watching on air
and having to Google who our own joke
was because it had been so long since
the joke was pitched in the end American
Dad moved away from politics to remain
more relevant in
reruns going too far American Dad can
push the envelope in terms of content
but there have been only a few times
cast or crew drew a line Patrick Stewart
who plays CIA director Avery bulock
didn't want to deliver a joke that
strongly suggested his character was a
pedophile according to a 2012 San Diego
ComicCon panel even though Stuart had no
qualms earlier about singing a
suggestive Oingo Boingo song I I I love
little girls they make me feel so good I
love little girls they make me feel so
bad another instance of self-editing
personally involved co-creator Seth
McFarland there was a reference in a
script to a character having lost a lot
of weight or as the original script
called it doing a reverse Jason seagull
McFarland who's friends with seagull
asked for a rewrite writers gave Steve's
voice actor Scott Grimes the option to
say Russell Crow which then made Grimes
uncomfortable they ultimately decided on
Vince vaugh but still recorded him
saying Russell crow in case it was
funnier pulled from the schedule it's
not just a few lines that have had to be
cut from The Script at least twice
episodes were significantly delayed so
they wouldn't seem to make light of
national tragedies in April 201 11 Fox
planned a night of crossover episodes
where a hurricane would impact the lives
of characters on all three of Seth
McFarland's animated shows American Dad
Family Guy and The Cleveland Show in the
weeks leading up to that event storms
and tornadoes ravaged the southeastern
United States and fox pulled the
hurricane themed episodes pushing night
of the hurricane to October 2011 the
following year the American Dad episode
minstral Krampus was scheduled to air on
December 16th the Christmas themed
episode included an extremely violent
scene in which Santa and Stan Smith
stormed the castle where the mythical
creature Krampus lives violently killing
Beauty and the Beast styled animated
objects just before it aired Fox removed
minstral Krampus from its schedule in
light of that week's tragic school
shooting at Sandy Hook elementary school
in Connecticut the episode ultimately
aired a year later the Musical cast
American Dad employs some top-notch
vocal talent and some of its cast
members have such skilled and varied
vocal abilities that they've released
albums in 2012 Rachel McFarland who
voices Haley Smith released an album
called Haley sings a collection of
sultry nightclub Jazz the American Dad
episode love ad style in which Haley
becomes a nightclub singer features a
couple of songs from the album Scott
Grimes whose vocal talents are also
often used in the show has released
three albums a self-titled pop record in
1990 living on the run in 2005 and drive
in 2010 and singing traditional pop
standards with a big band is just one of
Seth McFarland's many jobs he's made
three albums of the stuff music is
better than words holiday for swing and
no one ever tells you which actually hit
number one on Billboard's jazz albums
chart have a great night bye have a
beautiful time Underdog Productions in
card for every episode of American Dad
uses a video of a smiling man giving a
wave and a thumbs up usually wishing
everyone a good night bye have a great
time according to the show's DVD
commentaries he's a guy identified only
as security officer paa who worked at
the building where Underdog Productions
makes the show paa no longer works there
but his presence remains a fixture at
the end of each episode even when he's
not there come back you guards I'll kill
you I'll hunt you down and kill
you bye have a beautiful
day overdoses relapses and Rehab doesn't
sound like a recipe for a successful
comedy But Chuck Lori pulled it off for
eight seasons with his Smash Hit
mom if you've ever dreamed of making it
in Showbiz and need a bit of inspiration
check out Chuck Lor's story Lori the
creator of mom along with a host of
other hit coms spent many years broke
and struggling before finally breaking
through in his mid-30s as he told the
Lancing State Journal I remember vividly
what it's like to put 38 cents in the
gas tank and drive to my second cousin's
house so they would feed me before
hitting it big in television however
Lori spent some time dabbling in another
creative profession songwriting and if
you're wondering whether any of his
songs became well known we've got four
words for you Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles yes if you've ever gotten the
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles theme song
stuck in your head you can thank Lori
who co-wrote the catchy song that helped
Define the franchise as for his comedy
writing dream that didn't really happen
until he got a job writing for the
groundbreaking sitcom Roseanne a major
break that opened doors launching him on
a career trajectory like no other after
Roseanne Lori went on to become one of
the most successful sitcom creators in
history responsible for the hits Grace
Under Fire syil and Dharma and Greg but
Lori really hit the jackpot with Two and
a Half Men And The Big Bang Theory the
pair of Mega hits which gave him the
would cred to make Mom happen and even
though Lori is a rarity a sitcom sangali
with multiple Mega hits under his belt
any aspiring writer can find inspiration
in his rags to richest
tale before Mom Anna Ferris was best
known for her roles in comedies like
just friends The House Bunny and the
scary movie franchise with her
distinctive comedic chops and bubbly
blonde Persona she was the first actor
CBS approached for Mom Ferris told pop
sugar that her husband at the time actor
Chris Pratt actually read the script for
Mom before she she did and by the time
he got to the second page he was
convinced the role was perfect for her
saying honey whatever you're doing stop
now and read this even though television
has come a long way since the days where
everything edgy was on HBO Ferris and
jany agreed that Mom dealt with risky
issues for Network sitcom during a joint
interview with Larry King when King
asked feris if she was ever surprised by
the content of the show she revealed
that she was constantly shocked by how
far the writers were willing to push it
saying on a weekly basis when we get the
new scripts I always say are we sure CBS
is okay with this before Mom Allison
Janney was best known for her role as
White House Press Secretary Claudia Jean
Craig also known as CJ on The West Wing
fans may be surprised to learn that she
didn't have her breakthrough role on The
West Wing until she was 40 which is
pretty unusual by Hollywood standards
Janney did have a steady stream of
supporting movie and TV roles before
then but nothing as big as the West Wing
which eventually led to mom on mom
Allison jany's character Bonnie had long
flowing auburn hair her qua actually
became synonymous with the character
which was a bit ironic considering that
it's not even Janie's real hair yep the
actor was wearing a wig the whole time
and her co-workers didn't even know
Janie's real hair is actually a
beautiful shade of natural silver and
when she showed up on set without the
wig one day The Producers apparently
freaked during an appearance on The
Tonight Show starring Jimmy Fallon jany
told the tale how are we going to
do you should have asked us before you
did this to your hair and I'm like guys
I've been wearing a wig since season 1
but no one nobody knew it as a
recovering addict himself mom was a very
personal show for Chuck Lori who got
sober himself at the age of 47 as he
told TV Guide sobriety is a big part of
my life and it's been that way for
almost 13 years I'm eternally grateful
I've been able to find this in my life I
am trying so hard I quit drinking I'm
going to meetings as far as how his
personal recovery Journey relates to Mom
Lori told indiewire broken people trying
to repair their lives I can relate to
that I think we're all in the process of
doing a little mending excuse me no
one's going to be snorting any fat rails
while I'm here and As jany Told
indiewire in another interview it feels
like a very grown-up show for Chuck Lori
I had no idea that we were going to be
going to the places that we've gotten to
go with
mom in Show Business like any other
business success breeds success and in
Chuck Lor's case having so many hits on
his resume gave him the freedom to take
on riskier stuff in other words shows
like two and a half men gave him the
freedom to make Mom Lori told indiewire
that to challenge himself creatively he
needed to tackle something different
something that would force him to step
into new areas of Comedy I am at a point
in my career where I can take some
chances if you're going to experiment do
something that is Meaningful to you if
you fail you did something meaningful to
you and with Mom he did just that
someone spoiling themselves actually
it's for my mom a she's a drug addict
who just got a out of
jail a back in the 1970s legendary TV
producer Norman Lear was a household
name he had many Creations to his name
but none as groundbreaking as All in the
Family which dealt with topical issues
and proved that TV sitcoms could be
intelligent and thought-provoking Chuck
Lori often credits Lear for inspiring
him to create similarly edgy sitcoms
proving to the world that television
doesn't have to be predictable and it
doesn't need to be insulting to the
intelligence of the audience in an
interview with variety Lori said that
with Mom he wanted to tell stories that
could take place in what he calls a
Norman Lear World in other words realism
rather than fantasy you know the
definition of insanity yes I know the
definition of insanity I live with you
Lear now 100 years old and someone Lori
considers A friend brought a reality to
the sitcom format that had never been
seen before and much like Lori has done
with Mom Lear made history tackling
tough subjects on TV as well in an
interview with the Los Angeles Times
Lear noted people will tell you you
can't do just about anything mention
abortion have a gay character write
funny about cancer you do it anyway
Christy plunket Jill's
sponsor but I'm not responsible for this
it was a big surprise to the viewers of
mom that the character of jod played by
Emily Osmond had a fatal overdose and
died on the show at that point jod had
reached 6 months of sobriety Lori has
said it was decided that Jody would have
an overdose when she was first
introduced to the show he explained the
reasoning behind this in an interview
with TV and Insider recovery from
addiction is fragile the one day at a
time Trope is sadly true it's a
vulnerable state of being that requires
vigilance you can't ignore it the entire
cast of mom was heartbroken when they
read the script and realized that jod
was going to die on the show not only
did they love the character but they
loved Osman as well it was a challenge
for the writers of mom to figure out how
to bring tragedy to the show and then go
back to being a comedy But ultimately
Jody's death showed that life goes
on laughter is contagious and the shared
experience of laughing can make a comedy
even funnier this is why it was so hard
to shoot mom when the covid-19 pandemic
took away its live audience something I
said changed the course of your life for
the
better yeah feels like it are you
listening to this veteran TV director
James widows Who helmed episodes of mom
agreed with that assessment speaking to
variety he called shooting the sitcom
during the pandemic a logistical
challenge like no other Gemma Baker the
co-creator of mom told deadline that not
having a live audio was one of the
hardest parts of finally ending the
series an audience was so much a part of
what we did and this whole season we
missed them it really was a huge loss to
not have that energy and feedback and
laughter it would have been great if we
could have ended the season in front of
a live
audience when Anna Ferris announced that
she was leaving Mom after seven seasons
it was a big shock to say the least and
while it's hard for a show to survive
when a lead character leaves it isn't
unheard of similar to Chuck Lor's other
hit sitcom 2 and a Half Men mom was able
to hang in in there for a little while
longer putting out one more season
however co-creator Gemma Baker wishes
they could have done more with Christy
telling deadline there were so many
things that we wanted to address that we
didn't get a chance to if we had a
little more time we would have gotten a
chance one storyline fans missed out on
was seeing how Christy would have done
at Georgetown University law school
Baker described how she imagined it
Christy would have faced some challenges
But ultimately would have overcome them
Baker went on to tell deadline how she
envisioned closure for Christie I like
to think that christe got into to a
happy and healthy relationship and that
she is still a part of her mother's life
fans can have a lot of power when it
comes to saving a show case in point the
original Star Trek series about to be
canceled after the second season NBC's
Deluge of letters from fans begging the
network to keep it on saved it the cop
drama Kagney and Lacy has a similar
story after it was cancelled a letter
writing campaign kept it on the air and
when Mom was officially canceled in
February 2021 fans mobilized with a
50,000 signature petition and those fans
who were in recovery were particularly
passionate to them it was important for
the show to remain on the air because of
the fact that so many addicts were
struggling during the pandemic as the
petition stated mom has been a crucial
voice in destigmatizing addiction this
show has no doubt saved countless lives
by promoting substance abuse recovery
and encouraging people to seek help
while the show did end up going off the
air the spirit of mom and how it gave a
voice to people in recovery will carry
on a lot of sitcoms have endings where
everything ends up just fine and
everyone lives happily ever after but
for a show like Mom having everything
wrapped up with a neat little bow at the
end just wouldn't work my name is Bonnie
and I'm a grateful alcoholic co-creator
Gemma Baker also didn't want a
convenient ending for the show telling
The Hollywood Reporter because of the
nature of the show it didn't feel
truthful to have an ending where
everything is tied up because the show
has always really been about reality and
characters showing up for Life On Life's
terms I think it's true what we say here
don't leave before the
miracle Baker recalled how the finale
was hard to put together because they
wanted to bring the show to a cloth in a
way that was meaningful and that did the
best for the characters and the audience
as well a challenging feat even under
the best of circumstances made more
difficult by the sudden departure of the
lead we'll be there every step of the
way damn
straight but it could also be seen as
fitting how in the end the characters
and the creative staff had to make the
best of a tough situation and deal with
life on life's terms
forgiven the ending to this crafty
little show is a bit controversial among
fans at least each character got their
own individual sendoff here are the most
important How I Met Your Mother
character endings ranked from worst to
best as how I met your mother's resident
leio Barney Stinson who's always clad in
a crisp suit and will stop at nothing to
bed every woman in New York seems like
he'll never change his wild ways however
as the show progresses Barney who seems
the least likely of anyone to settle
down realizes he's in love with Robin to
Ted's great shame the feeling is
shockingly mutual after several seasons
of tumultuous on again off again
relationships the two finally tie the
knot and their wedding weekend becomes
the sole focus of how I met your
mother's ninth and final season in the
series finale Barney goes through a ton
of difficult changes and neither the
character nor the audience is really
given any time to process them after
three difficult years of marriage he and
Robin apparently get divorced Robin
returns to her career and Barney returns
to his old ways until something
completely unexpected happens he gets a
girl pregnant and becomes the father of
a daughter you are the love of my life
suddenly Barney becomes a judgmental
horror yelling at women in bars about
what their fathers might think and
leaning into the overprotective dad Vibe
with the Zeal of a convert Barney turns
out to be a layered complex character
but his ending is oversimplified at best
and flat out offensive at worst after
Watching Ted spend nearly the entirety
of How I Met Your Mother searching for
the mother in the title expectations
were high and ultimately they were met
in full by Kristen mot's sweet Pitch
Perfect portrayal of Tracy McConnell she
meets Ted as they argue over an umbrella
they've both owned on a rainy train
platform through throughout the final
season we get small glimpses into Ted
and Tracy's relationship we also finally
learn about Tracy a process of viewer
education that culminates in the
standout 9th season episode how your
mother met me after the show laid the
groundwork of their relationship for the
entire 9th season fans were enraged when
during the series finale Tracy dies of
an unnamed illness and Ted moves on the
entire series's framing device is
revealed to be a guilty Ted telling his
teenage children about their dead mother
yikes thanks to the speed of the
finale's overstuffed epilogue Ted's
entire life with Tracy and her untimely
death happens in a matter of minutes
providing a pretty unfair ending to the
show's eminently lovable Title Character
on the surface it seems like Robin has
one of the best endings in all of How I
Met Your Mother when you look closer
however you can see the obvious flaws
after her divorce from Barney Robin
becomes a famous International
journalist constantly jet setting around
the world world but missing her friends
she finds it difficult to be around the
old gang again after her ex-husband gets
back to his womanizing ways she
continues her close relationship with
Lily and eventually finds her way back
into the fry not only does she go to Ted
and Tracy's wedding but she makes peace
with Barney by 2030 Robin Is Anchored in
New York once again in the final scene
Ted shows up at her door to win her back
with the blessing of his talked out
teens she finally gets everything she
ever wanted yes clumsily shoving Robin
and Ted together at the end of the
series which indicates that Robin a
smart and strong woman was pining for
Ted this entire time is just insulting
to the amazing character the showrunners
built along the way no matter how
tumultuous her life had been the robin
that emerges from season 9 would not
have settled for
Ted throughout the show two characters
hold an incredible amount of importance
but almost never say a word Ted's future
children penny and Luke Mosby for what
feels like years Penny and Luke sit
patiently and listen to their father's
wildly rambling story which takes plenty
of tangents and detours along the way
before he actually gets to the part
about how he met their mother Penny and
Luke get to reveal the show's final
twist and helped their dad move on with
his life in the aftermath of their
mother's death the point of the story is
that is that you totally totally totally
have the hots for Aunt Robin Not only
was that twist fairly unpopular but it
was the only time in the show the kids
had an actual say in the story aside
from Robin one of Ted's girlfriends
always loomed large over the series
Victoria the impossibly adorable Baker
Ted meets at a wedding during the Show's
first season though the two immediately
strike up a relationship everything is
put on pause when Victoria gets the
opportunity to move to Germany for work
and while she's away Ted cheats on her
with Robin ending the relationship for
the first time during the seventh season
Victoria reappears but makes it clear to
Ted that his continued involvement with
Robin and Barney despite the Trio's
awkward combination of romantic
entanglements is just too weird however
at the end of that season Ted and
Victoria reconnect on the day of her
wedding and she leaves her boyfriend for
him restarting their relationship once
again in the end Ted and Victoria aren't
meant to be and Victoria returns to
Germany after she presents Ted with an
ultimatum that he must stop talking to
Robin and he refuses at least Victoria
got to move abroad and keep living out
her culinary dreams we'll call it a win
there's no denying that Ted Mosby gets
one of the best endings of anybody on
the show but considering how difficult
his character can be to handle at times
this is ultimately a pretty frustrating
outcome in the end Ted gets everything
he wanted and then some despite the fact
that he shows himself to be selfish
self-righteous and entirely overbearing
toward the women in his life nice guys
really do finish last and emotionally
manipulative soft boys sometimes not a
win after striking up a perfect yet
doomed relationship with Tracy Ted seems
entirely settled as a single dad and it
seems as if he's put his idealistic stop
at nothing romantic attitude in the
rearview mirror however after his kids
encourage him to resume his quest for
Robin a gr Ted is back to his old tricks
standing outside of Robin's window and
triumphantly holding up the blue french
horn he stole for her way back in the
first season Ted may be the show's main
character but he can also be its most
grading so to see him get both a perfect
marriage and the woman of his dreams
feels slightly
unearned out of everyone on How I Met
Your Mother few characters deserved a
perfect ending as much as Lily the kind
sweet glue that holds the entire gang
together time and time again Lily always
looks out for her friends and loves her
husband and babyon Marvin but after
spending years as a kindergarten teacher
she finds herself yearning for greater
professional achievement later in life
luckily Lily gets offered the job of her
dreams as an art consultant but
unluckily it requires moving to Italy
which causes friction between her and
Marshall when push comes to shove
Lillian Marshall along with Marvin and
their newborn daughter Daisy do spend a
year in Italy which doesn't prevent
Marshall from pursuing his dreams either
later they have a second daughter after
years of helping others from her
students to her friends Lily finally
gets to live her best life in Italy as a
professional art consultant a dream
years in the making Far and Away the
sweetest character on the show Marshall
Erikson is defined by three things his
love for Lily his Devotion to his
friends and his quest to save the world
from certain Doom as an environmental
lawyer Marshall's Ambitions finally pay
off when during the show's ninth and
final season his application to become a
judge is approved and he has offered a
recently vacated seat on the bench this
incites a rift between Marshall and Lily
however as he doesn't immediately tell
her that their move to Italy conflicts
with his opportunity to become a New
York judge in the end when Marshall
finds out Lily is pregnant with Daisy he
immediately agrees to follow her to
Italy and continues working in corporate
law until another seat on the bench
opens up for him Happily One does upon
their return to New York and Marshall is
ultimately elected to the New York state
supreme court in 2020 fulfilling his
dreams of helping the world the only
recurring character on How I Met Your
Mother to appear in all of the show's
nine Seasons driver ronet Singh is
present for nearly every significant
moment in each main character's life
this also means ronit is present for a
lot of the gang's immature nonsense
including plenty of fights and squabbles
and even a bizarre subplot where Lily
inadvertently reveals that she had a sex
dream about ronet much to Marshalls
shock and disgust after years of driving
what appears to be the same five people
around New York City and the surrounding
area future Ted reveals in season 9 that
Ron Jeet ultimately starts an incredibly
successful limousine group and gets Rich
that's great because no one on this show
deserves happiness more than
ronit behind the scenes of friends
tapings there were some major misses
that had the live audience roaring for
all the wrong reasons as the cast
fumbled with their lines took occasional
pot shots at each other and simply could
not stop cackling about any of it what
do we smell in the season 4 episode the
one with Rachel's Crush it's Monica
Geller's fresh baked cookies that entice
all her friends to come come across the
hall before the scene could play out as
fans remember though there were a few
takes that didn't quite make it the cast
and crew had Matt Leblon to thank for
bringing a bit of toilet humor to the
mix responding to Lisa kudo's line what
do I smell with a koi adlib what do I
smell
sorry needless to say that wasn't in the
script this little adlib ended up
wasting a lot of time as Leblon and
co-star David schwimer simply couldn't
get past his oneline fart joke to finish
out the scene what do I
smell
BL eventually they managed to collect
themselves for long enough to make it
through the scene but it took a few
tries including one where they got so
close what do I smell I don't know it
smells good
mhm Ross didn't live live with Joey and
Chandler for long but he wore out his
welcome pretty quickly thanks to that
air purifier his obnoxious hand gestures
and the many many boxes of stuff he left
scattered across their living room the L
does prove to be a boon for the boys in
season fives the one where Ross moves in
once Joey realizes he can build a fort
with ross' stuff so why don't you be a
grownup and come and watch some TV in
the fort in the closing scene Chandler
comes home to find them playing Cowboys
and Indians in an innocent if culturally
insensitive moment the blooper re
version though now that was some racy
stuff what are you guys
doing nothing
nothing friends fans have often wondered
why Ross s so little of his son B
throughout the series but perhaps this
blooper reel can shed some light on that
creative decision in the one where Old
Yeller dies Ross is frustrated by how
many firsts he's been missing in the
boy's life and he wants to witness at
least one of those major mil stones for
himself to that end Ross tries to coax
the toddler into saying his very first
word during his visit as Ross takes Ben
to see Rachel at the coffee shop he
tries to talk baby into saying daada to
no avail can you say
Dada look I'm going to tell your mommy
as you said it anyway so you might as
well try no luck huh no for a couple of
takes however the tiny actor portraying
Ben didn't quite stick to the script you
know you might as well say it because I
told
you
the good news is that baby is growing up
to be sharp as attack the bad news is
it's the last thing the writers of this
episode want it to happen your mommies
you said it anyway so you might as well
try
huh yeah he's saying better who knew
Matthew Perry had such a pensent for
crappy jokes there were several
instances on friends when Chandler would
emerge from the bathroom for one reason
or another and as the blooper reels
reveal a lot of times the actor went off
script to make jokes about what he was
doing in there you girls got a measuring
tape eventually Courtney Cox decided to
play along and the results were pretty
great while filming a scene for the one
with the nap Partners in which Monica
confronts Chandler for breaking up with
a girl over her weight he was scripted
to be bothered by her knock at the
bathroom door instead he took another
approach honey you got to see this this
is like the size of my
arm cell phones have been ruining takes
since they could fit in people's pockets
but at least the results are often funny
during production on the one with Joey's
new brain Jennifer Aniston got a
legitimate call on her cell phone while
she and Lisa kud were filming a fight
about a different cell phone to quote
Phoebe what are the
chances well somebody's actually
here hello
hi let me call you right back I'm doing
a scene that wasn't the only cellular
mishap on the series though Aniston was
also the recipient of another unexpected
dial in while taping her birthday scene
on the set of the one where they all
turned 30 which just goes to show that
she was as widely reported very popular
during her time on the show better to be
over the
hill it comes with a
phone sometimes a blooper isn't an
accident sometimes it's a prank in the
one with the secret closet Joey has to
take a pregnant Rachel to the hospital
after she begins experiencing Braxton
Hicks contractions Ross shows up late
complaining about the between himself
and his baby's mother to be Schwimmer
had a hard time hitting his cues for the
scene though so Matt leelah and Jennifer
Aniston decided to pull a prank on him
after Schwimmer missed his Mark and had
to go back out of frame to try again the
two decided to hide and let him walk
into an empty room just to see what he'd
do later when he forgot his line during
a take Aniston playfully laid into him
for bringing the whole gang down and at
the uh movie
theater just suck what happened here you
used to be able to act I know remember
Joey's disastrous noodle soup commercial
audition with the kid who was a more
competent actor than him M soup I mean
noodle soup I mean soup come on well
life imitated art in that regard because
Cole sprous who portrayed Ben in the
later seasons of the show seemed to be
the only one who'd memorized the script
while shooting a scene with Jennifer
andison for the one with the truth about
London for example sprous confidently
fed her the missing line when she forgot
what to say now what is my first
line what did we agree
okay then when he shared the screen with
David Schwimmer for a scene in the one
with the holiday armadillo sprous had to
again remind his co-star of what to say
next you're part of oh
yeah so don't take any
go back I know all of his
lines Chandler and Monica's story line
in the one where Ross meets Elizabeth's
dad is kind of a throwaway the two have
a silly misunderstanding over what time
they're supposed to meet up for a mini
date and their snafu becomes SP for
Phoebe's next book chapter their
argument doesn't make many friends fans
lists of best moments of course but
perhaps it would have if it had gone
down the way it did in the bloopers
Chandler we said we would meet at the
coffee house at 6 we said seven you dumb
bag of all the cast members who were
paired for two-person scenes throughout
friends Lisa kudro and David schwimer
had to be among the most entertaining
Phoebe is never afraid to call Ross on
his worst decisions and since she seems
to be the one woman in his life who is
neither a relative nor an ex she's often
his go-to friend for unbiased advice the
two also get into a lot of weird
situations together including the time
that they each date half of a divorcing
couple and start bickering with each
other in the one with the engagement
picture as their arguments started to
mimic the separated couple David
schwimer and Lisa kudro had a lot of
trouble keeping it together and
finishing their scenes and she uses sex
as a weapon
fine things got so out of hand that
schwimer suggested shooting the scene
line by line which kudro seemed game for
apparently it had worked out pretty well
for her before we'll just do the scene
one line at a
time I got one I'll you I got it Emmy as
friends Joey and Chandler definitely
find comfort in each other they're known
to hug so often that they eventually
have to ask themselves if it's getting
out of hand in the season 6 episode the
one with the mac and cheese during
shooting all of the repeated hugs and
back rubs started to get under their
skin any while we're here anything
else get off me then things really went
off the reels when the mats decided to
lean into the discomfort of prolonged
physical contact what's that in your
pocket after so many seasons of bringing
the Friends cast to life the actors
started to know their characters all too
well while filming a scene for the
season 8 episode the one with the
birthing video David schwimer realized
midline just how much of a dope his
character was for letting his pregnant
ex-wife move in with him while he had a
new girlfriend and neither he nor Lisa
kudro could stop laughing about it I
knew it I knew I wasn't crazy for a
while all the actor can seem to do is
sit there and think about Ross's bad
decisions eventually Kudo has to ask him
if he's really so surprised all right
ready have you ever seen the
[Music]
show